foreign
good evening
there are no planned flyer drills so if
the alarm goes off please leave the
building in an orderly fashion through
the nearest fire exit please use either
the fire exit through the main doors of
the hall or the fire exit to the store
room adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is in the island
at is the island sorry at the front of
the main entrance to the building please
do not delay your evacuation to collect
any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please also switch off mobile phones or
turn them to silent please note that the
toilet in hand washing facilities are in
the foyer area
members of the public once you are of
course entitled to film or take
photographs during this meeting can I
please emphasize to you that this should
be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area in the public seating
can I please therefore ask you to raise
your hand clearly in the air
if you wish to take photographs of film
this evening thank you very much
please members be upstanding to receive
the chairman and chief executive
good evening members and members of the
public please be seated
oh
members
when I invite you to speak please wait
until there's a microphone in front of
you before speaking
as microphones are needed for the
hearing Loop and for the audio recording
they are all switched on and ready for
you to speak
so you do not need to adjust them
please make sure that the microphone is
directly in front of you before speaking
members
voting will be done with a show of hands
in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands
for then against
and then recommendation for the
recommendations and then for abstaining
given the size of the room and the
members
of us present can I please ask you that
you put your hand up clearly
high in the air
so that you can be easily seen by all
and leave it up until you are asked to
blow it
members the normal rules of debate apply
no members should speak for longer than
five minutes
and I can
and can I please ask you do not repeat
anything previously said
all those indicating to speak will be
given an opportunity to speak once
members
um item one
apologies
apologies have been received from
councilor Tracy Knight
and councilor Robert Miller are there
any others
no one said
thank you
members Declaration of Interest item two
members on Tuesday the 14th of February
2023 you received an email from the
Democratic Services advising you that
the monitoring officer had issued a
dispensation for members for tonight's
budget meeting
covering the setting of the council tax
or
or a precept under the Local Government
Act Finance Act
members are there any other Declarations
of Interest
members gender item three
budget
2023 to 2024
a median term Financial strategy
the report will be introduced by the
leader of the council councilor Simon
Wooten
thank you chairman
members the meeting tonight is one of
the most important in the municipal year
it is vital that we have a robust and
sustainable financial plan for our
future in order to continue to deliver
the many important Services the council
provides both statutory and non-statutry
our key strategic goal as a council is
to be a modern accessible and
financially sustainable Council
delivering excellent value for money
services to Residents and businesses in
the district at a proportionate and
reasonable cost from the taxes and
charges we Levy as an authority
quite apart from our legal obligations
it is our Collective responsibility as
all councilors across this room not just
the conservative Administration to
ensure we represent our residents in a
fiscally responsible manner and that we
recognize the financial challenges we in
common with other authorities face
which includes considerable volatility
on a number of factors affecting local
government finances not least
inflationary pressures
not wishing to minimize that challenge
the budget I'm proposing tonight for
Rochford District Council would be the
Envy of many councils across England and
Wales and some much closer to home here
in Essex
members you will have read the detailed
reports covering items three and four of
our agenda tonight
what we have before you tonight are
significant
a balanced budget with no funding Gap
and therefore no need to have any
subsidy from Reserves
no debt
no interest payments no Capital
repayments no Lending
no cuts to services
support to the financially vulnerable
within our community Through council tax
support and hardship funding Community
grants capital investment in our
buildings estate
a commitment to make the mill arts and
Event Center in Rady a jewel in the
crown for local residents as well as
developing community and office
facilities in The Freight House in
Rochford
we have excellent Leisure facilities in
both Clements Hall and Rayleigh Leisure
centers
and we are proposing a significantly
less than inflation proposal to increase
council tax by 2.97
equivalent to 7 pounds 29 Pence per year
or put another way an extra 14 Pence per
week on a band D property
under my leadership this Council has
striven to ensure transparency in the
way we conduct our business
I should like at this point to thank
Naomi Lucas the former section 151
officer and more recently Tim Lewis our
current interim director of resources
for all the briefings they have given to
all members in this Council to support
and help understanding on the council on
the complex subject of council subject
finances
as I now turn to the slides I genuinely
believe there's a lot to be positive
about and I'll be highlighting some of
our successes
but I also want to be honest about some
of the challenges and to explain that to
govern is to choose and there are
serious consequences resulting from
those choices
if I can turn first of all to the second
slide please
thank you
this time last year
we balance the budget for 2022 to 23 but
had a predicted budget Gap in 2324 and
24 25.
that the pay award in 2022
turned out to be a lot higher than we
thought we had assumed two percent and
that was a reasonable assumption at that
time
but the
1925 pounds paid to every employee added
around seven percent to the pay bill
we also hadn't anticipated Russia's
invasion of Ukraine two days after we
set the budget
this clearly had a major effect on
inflation
despite this through careful financial
management we are forecasting to more or
less Break Even this financial year
but inflation will have a large impact
on next year's budget
if we can turn to slide three please
now I appreciate there's not much chance
unless you've got super eyesight for
being able to read that but all the
details are in the in the pack but I
just want to remind members that we have
a business plan and we talk about our
key achievements and all these points
are under our business plan
so if we go from left to right and I'm
not going to go through all of them but
we establish with great success the
Rochford North joint venture to deliver
waste collection and Street cleansing
services
we carried on with the progression of
the one team partnership with Brentwood
Borough Council
which for our Authority gives us the
opportunity to achieve economies of
scale through through those benefits
opportunity and resilience
we're progress progressing four major
connect project project projects to
improve efficiency and delivery
we have
worked hard to support our residents
with a cost of living Campaign which has
been acknowledged by others independent
of this Authority as actually leading
the way in how this council is
supporting residents through the cost of
living campaign
we've invested a hundred thousand pounds
in the Hockley Woods play Space another
hundred thousand pounds of investment in
Hockley Woods car park
and the purchase of 2.2 million pounds
of refused vehicles
with enhanced pedestrian and cycle
safety
we've delivered or are in the process of
delivering
copies of Rochford District matters to
every household in the district and that
was certainly in response to many
residents talking to us about the need
to
find out what the council and and
recognize that not everyone wants to do
this digitally sometimes they appreciate
something coming through their front
door and that's a magazine which is
arriving on doormats as we speak
if we can turn to the next slide thank
you
as I said earlier there's lots of
uncertainty about inflation as well as
well as the government's plans that
affect local government
for example the plan changes to the
business rate system and new homes bonus
as well as the way that waste is managed
our proposed budget is for a small
contribution to reserves next year
compared to this time last year there
have been large swings in both income
and expenditure when setting the
2023-24 budget but it is a balanced
budget
it does depend on a council tax increase
of 2.97 as set out in the report
this as I said earlier equates to only
14 Pence per week on a band D property
and rochford's is the lowest percentage
increase of all the preceptors
although any increase in council tax
places an additional burden on
households it is modest when compared to
inflation and that inflation has had a
significant impact on the council's own
expenditure
the contribution to reserves is needed
because we have a general fund balance
or working balance that we seek to
maintain at 10 of net revenue
expenditure
the fifty thousand pounds contribution
to reserves will enable this working
balance to be kept at 1.2 million pounds
which equates to 10 percent
as the slide shows we aim to keep this
Reserve topped up to maintain it roughly
at the required level
if we can move to the next slide please
which picks up on the
major budget pressures and savings
we should celebrate the fact as I said
earlier that unlike many councils we're
not talking about cuts to services
there is no be no need to go through an
exercise to salami slice Savings in
services
instead the way we plan to deliver
savings over the next three years is
primarily through our strategic
partnership with Brentwood Borough
Council
partnership is designed to increase the
resilience of services whilst also
delivering Financial savings through the
economies of scale
every organization can be more efficient
and we in Rochford are no different
by working with Brentwood we aim to
learn from them and others as well as
show them what we do well so they can
learn from us
the new shared teams will deliver
Services more efficiently but always
preserving the sovereignty of this
Council
we have been able to reduce the amount
we pay into our pension fund each year
by 395
000 pounds based on the latest
evaluation of the fund
this is true of most councils it is good
news but I don't claim credit for this
just as I can't be blamed for some of
the extra cost pressures due to external
factors
we have also benefit from benefited from
business rates revaluations worth 680
000 pounds and the new homes bonus of
eight hundred and forty thousand pounds
what definitely is down to this
council's good financial management is
that we predict an extra 250 000 pounds
income from Investments
these are very safe Investments what
this shows is that Rising interest rates
rather than being the cost and a risk to
our finances are actually good news in
the sense that we can earn more from our
cash Holdings
but of course we know that higher
interest rates as well as inflation
increases the whole the cost of living
to our residents and businesses
this is why we have continued the
support through our cost of living
response for example Council last week
agreed financial help to council
taxpayers
apart from the cost pressures on pay and
inflation we have included an extra
provision in the budget to keep open the
Mill arts and Event Center
we have also included the cost of food
waste separation which was reported
again to council last week
so if we can go through the next few
slides
and again under our business plan
our financial sustainability
and I think as I said this is all in the
report but hopefully members can can
read that
you want me to read it read it out to
that
I'm getting notes don't need to right
okay
I'll leave you for a few moments to
absorb that
and if we can move on to the Early
Intervention slide please
and move on to maximizing our assets
and the next slide to enable communities
I believe we've actually got some paper
copies a limited number here tonight but
certainly more copies can be made
available for everyone of this
presentation
please
nothing against councilor Wootton but
are the are these slides any different
to what we've read in the paperwork I
cannot read them by the I think the
council is aware of my color blindness
and the whites merging into the whatever
color it's on which I don't know so if
this is fundamental to the vote I need a
paper copy if it's what I've read
already in the reports I've read it
that's all
I apologies uh to members and
Big Bear was just a second too
is there some more copies
foreign
please
thank you chairman um
I appreciate on picking out the
highlights but all of these details are
actually in the report which has been
circulated under item three tonight
in terms of the capital strategy this
slide is a summary of appendix 2 of the
report
the capital program is enabling many of
the Ambitions that I've just been
talking about
we have major investment plans two
million pounds for our Waste Services
and 4.2 million pounds for the asset
development program
all this expenditure needs to be funded
many councils would borrow to fund their
Capital program
because they don't have the Reserves
we do we have some Capital receipts
along with the hard soft infrastructure
reserve and the investment Reserve
here is one of those choices that I
spoke about earlier
should we borrow four million pounds and
keep the four million pounds in reserves
for something else
this Council for many years has decided
not to borrow and I'm proud to have
continued that policy
that is not to say that we should not
rule out borrowing forever to fund the
right project one that offers genuine
long-term savings or secures long-term
income that can cover the principal and
interest payments on the debt
if I talk in particular about the
community safety fund
last year and the year before we made
provision for one hundred thousand
pounds
to be given to
town and Parish councils on a matched
funding basis
the majority of the share was going to
go to Rayleigh Town Council for them to
develop their CCTV project
for various reasons not least the
procurement vagaries of local government
it hasn't been possible for for us to
deliver that
so we are stopping for the next year
that hundred thousand pounds but instead
making a hundred and twenty thousand
pounds available to develop
CCTV across our district but starting in
Rayleigh
we know that is something that the
residents have called for
and we agree
and using our partner with Brentwood
Borough Council who already have a CCTV
unit
we can actually
piggyback on the back of that Network
to drive in CCTV in Rayleigh and I'm
hoping that can be rolled out to other
parts of our district over time
that is what the 120 000 pounds is for
but it is also a community safety budget
for us to
look at enforcement look at neighborhood
watch schemes look at Street pasta
schemes and generally look at areas of
community safety within our district
we also plan to make available
up to one thousand pounds to each Parish
Council and of course ready Town Council
towards an event to celebrate the king's
coronation
in May
and also under the capital strategy
we've also been able to protect the
street Ranger service
that was operated by Essex County
Council
so if we look at the next slide
I thought this would be quite a good
slide to put in there because it very
graphically shows the proportion of the
overall council tax precept that
Rochford actually takes
it is 12 percent We Are The Collection
Authority for all authorities Essex
County Council Essex fire police and
crime commissioner Town town and Parish
councils and of course ourselves our
share of that is 12 percent
2.97 7 pounds 29. we always use a band d
as the um as the hundred percent if you
like property that we quote so their
council tax their element from Oxford
District Council will increase some 245
pounds 16 Pence to 252 pounds 45 Pence
so I thought that would be a um a good
good slide to to show
and if we come back to the next slide
which is simply the budget headlines
that I've been through
2.97 increase in council tax
no service reductions continuing to
support the most vulnerable in the
district
no debt a corporate strategy delivery
to build on the Strategic partnership
with Brentwood
and future years uncertainty that has to
be acknowledged but a balanced medium
term Financial strategy
so that members completes the slides
but I will finish off by saying I'm
proud to be presenting this budget to
you tonight
there are very many councils across the
country that are facing far tougher
decisions than ours perhaps because they
have suffered an unexpected Financial
hit or because they have not managed
their financial affairs as well as
Rockford
we will all know of a few that are
having to seek external help with big
decisions being taken out of their hands
because of their financial predicament
a defining feature of this and previous
budgets is to remain debt free
as I have said I am open to the
principle of borrowing sound boring for
the right project
but let's celebrate the fact that we
have no debt we have been able to inject
250 000 pounds into Service delivery
next year as a direct result of that
policy due to higher interest rates
those same higher interest rates would
for example add about two hundred and
fifty thousand pound costs to our budget
if we borrowed instead of using our
reserves to fund the capital program
that's two hundred and fifty thousand
pounds every year for 40 to 50 years
perhaps we don't have an exotic
portfolio of out of District Investments
or a hundred million pound flank chip
scheme
but I believe we are super ambitious
ambitious to keep providing excellent
services to our residents at a
reasonable cost
that may not attract the attention of
the national media but I believe it is
what the people of Rochford want from
their local Authority
I commend this budget to the council I
want to lead a council which is creative
and Innovative a council with
opportunity a council with vision and
ambition all in the interests of the
communities we serve
the evidence is already there and
history speaks for itself the work the
council is able to achieve is
underpinned by sound strategic Financial
Planning and robust financial management
which our administer Administration will
continue over the course of the next
financial year and Beyond
I therefore propose Mr chairman the
recommendations set out in item three
paragraph 17 Page 3.23
recommendations thank you Mr chairman
thank you
thank you chairman I would like to
Second those proposals and if I may just
say a few words
thank you
um firstly members would have seen a
rise in most fees and charges within
this budget and bringing Rochford in
line nationally most of them are in line
with them inflation I am however pleased
to say that car parking charges have not
been increased at all and neither have
any Cemetery charges
um I think this is good news for for
residents
as portfolio holder for climate finance
and economy I'm exceptionally proud of
the work this Council has done to
support our local businesses over the
past year and delighted that we have
been able to provide a budget to allow
this vital work for our economy to
continue
along with the ambitious task of
becoming carbon neutral by 2030 I'm
pleased that we have made funds
available for our ideas and more
importantly to employ a sustainability
officer to ensure the ideas are able to
come to fruition
in summary and as counselor Watson has
already set out for an additional 14
Pence per week not only can we prevent
any cuts to services but we have
actually set out a plan to increase them
along with our resources to keep
improving the service for our residents
I'm pleased to Second these motions
thank you okay
the first person I had wishes to speak
to this is counselor Mrs Mason
thank you
I would like firstly to thank councilor
Wootton for his details
I can move it much closer how's that
I'll try and move it up as well
yeah
firstly I'd like to thank councilor
Whitton for his detailed report
but I have concerns with some aspects as
people say the devil is in the detail
according to officers and comparing
previous budgets and reports the capital
program for the asset development
program has reduced by 1.5 million as a
result of funding for the Mill Hall
being removed in light of the decision
not to develop it
a reassessment of what was required for
other elements of the asset development
program including a reduced amount for
The Freight House Redevelopment
six hundred and twenty two thousand
pound was added to the revenue budget to
fund payment to GB Partnerships
so the reduction in the ADP between 2023
budget and the 2324 budget was not
redeployed
the asset development program is
currently being reviewed to reflect the
revised investment strategy
so it is too early to specify how the
4.2 million will be spent
the 4.2 million in the capital program
is a provision that is available to fund
the revised asset strategy
which will be presented to council at a
future date
the uncertainty
and lack of proper project plan that
calls with the financial position now
being made leads me to find it difficult
to support this aspect of the budget
at the proposed increases of 50 50
000 to General reserves and 290
000 earmarked reserves for Investments
at a time when our residents are
suffering unprecedented cost of living
increases
and
looking at the overall figures they
appear positive
until you appreciate the impact on
individual households
I believe that this budget will create
further hardship to many members of our
community and therefore with reluctance
I cannot and will not support it thank
you
next question on my list is councilor
Wilkinson
okay
oh that's better you can hear me now
chairman thank you first of all I'd like
to thank the leader and his
administration for the time and the
effort it's obviously taken to prepare a
budget it's obviously incumbent and the
administration to do so and it's not
lost on me the efforts that are that are
taken to do this my history of voting uh
this time of year will dictate that
actually historically I've supported
this
um The Stance and the reason for that
has always been the fact that I
recognize the fact that as costs
increase our Council costs increase
therefore our income needs to increase
in line with it so I've I've never had
never had a problem with it equally the
other reason I've never had a problem
with it in the past is because there's
always been investment
the last couple of years it's been in
CCTV there was um the year before last
there was this extra 100 000 pounds put
to one side for investment within
Capital uh sorry Community safety
projects
now when I looked at this when I looked
at this budget today when I looked at
these yesterday rather so I try and work
my way through the figures
um I tried to work out and I did speak
to the interim director for resources
about this yesterday we had a meeting
where I tried to get some clarification
of figures and thank you very much for
your time you spent
um as to why there's an increase from
the usual two percent to 2.97
and the reason I can see is because the
government's allowed us to because the
Autumn statement the chancellor has
allowed us to increase council tax
further than we ever have in the past uh
for the without a referendum okay well
if we're going to do that why are we
doing it well the way I see the reason
we're doing this is because it's to put
extra seventy thousand Pounds into our
reserves I know the figure of 50 000
pounds was mentioned but I was told that
this would bring in 250 000 pounds of
council tax we usually get 180 over 2
rise that's additional seventy thousand
pounds going into reserves stop going
into any projects going into any it's
going into Reserves
there's no way on Earth we can support
taking an extra seventy thousand pounds
after our residence Pockets simply just
to put in our Reserves at all
now there are some aspects of this
report that I agree with and I think
that there's a lot of there's a lot of
good in it but I think that you need to
pick as councilor Mrs Mason said you
need to pick the detail out of it
the leader talked about Good Financial
Management and yes there is a lot of
good financial management which goes on
with this Council there is but equally
there's some bad as well
and there's been some wasted money as
yet still undisclosed amount of boosted
money that went to GB Partnerships for
the failure of the contracts to do with
the building we're currently standing in
that would have a bearing on the budget
we are being asked to consider today and
I don't see how the 80 000 residents of
this District could be asked to fund
that mistake which is about essentially
what's being asked
um and I and so therefore whilst I do
agree with arise I always have our our
costs are going up I accept the fact
that our income needs to go with it I
cannot support an increase uh what's
been suggested where part of it is
simply going to go into reserves and not
being spent thank you
there's no Foster you did indicate
thank you chairman
um
the largest number of complaints I
receive from residents relate to
planning and enforcement
can you please confirm that the proposed
budget is sufficient to enable the
recruitment of experienced planners to
boost the performance in the planning
and enforcement department thank you
to whom you're asking that question
thank you chairman to the portfolio
holder for strategic planning
thank you chairman
in regards to that particular question
we're looking to begin
a Performance Management Service review
in March
we have a budget in place
and reasonable needs identified in the
upcoming review
the connect project
will greatly support the planning
department
leading to a better
improved service for all our residents
thank you
hear me
I apologize in advance because what I've
got to say will slightly cross over Mrs
Mason point but in a different vein
I've been through the medium term
financial report a number of times and
it seems to be a game of two halves
there's about 50 percent of the budget
is every day
Council Supply delivery and general
goings on for the council
that is supported in the report by an
in-depth cost
Expedition via areas charts and agenda
the schedule is also illustrated by
right up front by one fiscal year but
three years looking ahead considered as
the medium term
and section 13 deals with numerous
risks it's a risk register basically
it's alarmingly large but
I have to say the mitigation measures
are explained in some detail
and it does address
contingency and various moves that can
be made to offset some of the what might
happen and there seems to be an alarming
number of unknowns unsures and could
change issues so that goes along with
councilor wooten's point about
councils being up against up against it
financially at the moment
so I think that was pretty well covered
in that respect cost schedule and risk
management
conversely the other half of the budget
50 of the budget is capital projects
that doesn't meet that criteria at all
so I'd like to go down the bottom of the
document to section 14 which talks about
the robustness of the budget estimate
and all the various
criteria that needs to be met and so on
one of which is the financial officer
reporting and updating the strategy
quarterly to directors taking part in a
six monthly
review and then ultimately or the
leadership team on an annual basis
so if I roll back up again to the
capital budget
the new waste treatment project
it says 1.7 million so it's big enough
to worry about it I don't see any
schedule there any Milestones or any
risk management
not mentioned
The Mill Hall gets a mention but there's
no money time or risk associated with
that because what it's saying is that a
new
outline business case is required and
that in itself will start to introduce
cost schedule and risk but it's not
there at the moment so I see that as
done wrong
likewise the ADP project gets two
different mentions in the write-up and
the sum of 4.2 million appears to be the
residual amount of the original OBC
redeployed or left over
but neither reference acknowledges the
independent organ that was carried out
some months ago
who
summarize in Five Points three critical
too urgent
that completely
would change the scope of that statement
I believe
and therefore it's over in a nutshell
it's overall reference was it needs to
be re-looked at and a new OBC
and again the outline business case
would introduce cost schedule and risk
at the moment on all those three major
projects we can make up about 50 of the
budget none of those things are in place
so I would suggest respectfully that the
financial officer who's got to face the
music four times a year plus a half year
and a full year
really needs to set some milestone
deadlines for the OBC for the Mill Hall
to be submitted for the ovc for the ADP
to be submitted and for the Recently
sanctioned 1.7 million waste then that's
currently missing the schedule and the
risks so I think dates should be set in
the near future as deadlines to be met
for that information otherwise I don't
feel comfortable with a very good half
budget and are not very good at a half
budget that leaves me not with a lot of
confidence
so thank you for listening thank you
yes thank you chair
um it's it's useful that
it can you hear me yep
can you hear me now you think just a bit
nearer it's pretty close
um it's it's helpful that the counselor
mentioned the section 14 which is that
the piece that I write as the Council of
statutory finance officer to give
reassurance to all members that vote on
the budget
um that I can say professionally that
the amount of reserves that are set out
in the report are sufficient
um and that their the budgeting process
is adequate and I'll cover those two
areas first of all
um the level of reserves and I will take
this opportunity if I may to respond in
part to Council of Wilkinson as you
mentioned also this this section
um
the current policy of the council is to
set aside 10 of net revenue expenditure
as the leader indicated in his
presentation
that covers our working balance that
working balance which is 1.2 million
that equates to on the 12 million pound
budget
um
is there in case of emergencies and
section 13 refers to some of those risks
that could give rise to emergencies
which means we need to tap into
resources urgently
um you will see in the report that we're
only just about at that level on working
balances we're only just about 1.2
million uh the 10 of net revenue
expenditure forecast for next year and
Beyond
um and
um any income generation including the
recommended council tax increase
reflects the need to make sure that that
balance is sufficient in accordance with
existing policy which has underpinned
some of my recommendations in the
Assurance statement that I've provided
to the council
um
of course 50 000 here match to a seventy
thousand pound saving on only a two
percent increase in council tax is you
can match a number of different figures
throughout the report and say you could
do that or you might not want to do that
not necessarily council tax and and
reserves contribution
and that's a political decision for the
council to make but what I would say is
that
if a justification for reducing income
in the budget is we don't need to put so
much into reserves we do need that 50
000 contribution forecast for next year
into the work imbalance to maintain the
10 threshold which is set out in my
section 14 of the report
just coming on to the second issue I
think
in terms of the analysis of risk and the
lack of detail in relation to the
capital program really I think was was
the main issue and the lack of detail
around how the capital program is going
to be spent and what the risks might be
and attached to that program
um I think there's some validity to that
because typically with Revenue budgets
as opposed to Capital budgets Revenue
budgets are ongoing year in year out
type of spending like on salaries and
maintenance
um we have a lot more certainty about
the type of things we're going to spend
that money on because it's the same
things we spent the money on this year
and last year whereas the capital
program is by its nature of projects
they're things that we aspire to do
which could be new and we've not done
before
and to a greater or lesser extent we
have an idea of what we're going to do
and how we're going to do it but quite
often in respect to the capital program
we don't know that and what we put in
front of you for a program over the next
three years
there is a degree of uncertainty as to
how we will go about delivering on those
projects specifications need to be
written procurements need to be carried
out and what typically happens with the
capital program and we found this in
recent years is there's lots of other
things that happen that cause his
uncertainty not just the ones that might
be within our own control the risks that
we could generate ourselves but also
things like inflation
um the longer it takes to deliver a
project inflation has a bigger and
bigger impact the issues with lack of
materials and labor has meant that
there's been a lot of capital program
slippage which means we don't spend what
we think we're going to spend so there
are what I'm outlining are some of the
risks is actually the capital program
that are not just about not knowing
exactly how we're going to spend the
capital program that is is in front of
members tonight
I'm relatively relaxed about the fact
that the report as it's presented
doesn't have that level of detail in
relation to the program the capital
program projects because that's not
untypical at this stage in the process
of budget approval and the medium term
Financial strategy thank you
very quickly Mr Crypt Council sorry
hello are you there okay yeah I hear
what you say but I the threat we're
under across the board is
marketingly demonstrated in section 13.
it's right across the board that will
affect projects equally as anything else
and any new event the size of the money
we're talking there it's 50 of the
budget I believe that a project should
only a budget which is has a has a
built-in
contingency
and the responsibility for that budget
is to come in under that budget or at
least not above the contingency
now that starts with OBC which will give
you the first high level cost schedule
and risk list you've now got a degree
cash grips if you've got a point you
ought to have clarified please go ahead
but you've had your your time
unless you've got a point of
clarification then I'll ask you to sit
down okay okay I'll reiterate my point I
believe the financial officer should be
setting the deadline for when it gets
the obc's outstanding and the
information outstanding such that his
reports can start to Monitor and reflect
what's going on in projects thank you
thank you
members can I remind you that it is five
minutes uh it is being timed so please
make sure you stick to your five minutes
next lesson I have on the list is
councilor Stanley
thank you chairman
um
from the leaders
comments about the CCTV
can I ask him to assure
that the money that was put forward of
last year will be carried forward this
year
to rainy Town Council and what they and
what they want in the district not what
RDC want in the district but our TC want
in the district and that is to work with
a company that they believe is the right
company to work with not the hundred and
twenty thousand that's going to go
towards brentwood's ideas of CCTV or
anybody else's ideas it's RTC that have
been working on this for considerable
time and I am one of those that's been
working on it and trying to get this
move forward as quickly as possible and
we are dedicated to putting CCTV in
Brady High Street thank you okay Coastal
Stanley
respond to that
thank you chairman
there has been ongoing work with RDC and
RTC in fact the community safety officer
this department has spent a huge amount
of time working with various Partners to
look at a scheme so I don't think
there's any difference between what RTC
would like and what RDC surely the
answer is that we have a robust system
which serves the community and does its
job what that job looks like I don't
know but certainly you're suggesting
there might be a divide there's not a
divide at all it is doing the job that
is required but if I didn't make it
absolutely clear
what is happening is there is no
residual funding left from that 100 000
pounds other than to those Parish
councils who have genuinely started a
project and certainly we wouldn't
withdraw the funding if they're really a
contractual stage or whatever of
implementing a particular scheme my
understanding that is not the case with
CCTV that was the project that RTC were
working on and what we're actually doing
is not lining the pockets of our partner
Brentwood at all what we're actually
saying is we will actually meet all the
capital funding costs to install CCTV a
good system we will work with our
partner obviously there is a cost it
doesn't really matter whether that cost
goes within our partnership or whether
it passes out to an external contractor
actually if you ask me I'd prefer that
it stays within the partnership so that
we can all benefit from that but I'm not
precious about it the real thing is to
produce a system for Rayleigh that works
that is a robust system and certainly
there is no difference well the
difference is instead of 75 percent of
the capital cost to RTC RDC will pick up
a hundred percent of the costs and the
only commitment really for RTC and for
that matter any other Parish Council if
they want it they will meet the ongoing
Revenue costs thank you Mr chairman
oh he wants to come
on Teresa Stanley can I remind you it is
just for a point of clarification yes
yes oh I understand that from what our
leader has said that RDC will meet 100
of the capital costs and the management
side will be down to our TC I understand
that what I am asking really is that the
benefits of the company that we are
deliberating with far outweigh the
benefits of the company that he is
talking about and Andrew Padden
hasn't been elegant so it hasn't been
with us at all thank you thank you I
think those points have been noted
councilor Mrs Shaw
thank you chairman I fully support this
budget has been
lit and I'm very proud of what we have
achieved
and especially obtaining Professor Shaw
can you keep the mic oh sorry I thought
it sounded like it was echoing sorry
and especially obtaining monies for
taking on the vital ranges service thank
you to our members and officers involved
thank you
councilor ease is next on my list
teacher
three points if I may
uh first of all
um when we are looking at the
uh
section or page 3.8 the second paragraph
down
we have their uh statement that we are
looking at if it's 2.9 percent increase
in council tax with a assumed
increase of two percent annually after
that
everyone that has been speaking about
increases in costs
has been saying that we expect the
increases in costs to be considerable in
the future
so I'm intrigued to know why it is that
we're working on a two percent in future
years when everything that's been said
tonight would indicate that that would
be considerably more than that
that's my first point
um
secondly
in the risks list
there's no mention of the risk around
devolution
there obviously is going to be a risk on
that because we do not know how that is
going to pan out at the moment
and I know
colloquially that uh
a certain government Minister has said
that there is no more money in the pot
so it's going to be interesting to see
how that one works out
third point is directed at
assets when the leader very eloquently
brought the presentation to us in the
capital strategy under it tourism and
parking
we have a figure of 150 000.
now knowing the sort of money that has
been spent on it and parking
it leaves very little for tourism
now far from being Visionary this is
actually woeful when you consider the
amount of history that is in this area
um until recently the
portion of the website the council's
website actually under tourism had one
item on there it was an event that was
three years ago
and although it has been updated
uh the update doesn't actually give us
much more to actually hang on to so my
question there would be how do we see
tourism developing on the amount of
money that is actually allocated in the
budget thank you chair
Mr Willis did you wish to respond to
those points
thank you chair
um the first two points perhaps the
third one assembly also pick up
um the first point counselor is about
um
we assume two percent council tax
increases in twenty four five and twenty
five six
the increase in council tax is
limited by the threshold that applies
above which the council would have to
hold a referendum to increase by greater
than the threshold in previous recent
years it's been two percent for a number
of years
um for 23 24 it was three percent
exceptionally
um the government
in its recognition of extremely high
costs that the councils across the land
were facing they allowed council tax for
lowity authorities to go up three
percent without a referendum rather than
two percent so we're anticipating
um prudently that that threshold will
come back down after next year to two
percent as it's been for many years up
until 23 24.
um
we could put in a larger increase but
then that would assume that the council
wanted to vote for a referendum and then
the people of Rochford voted in favor of
a large council tax increase but we
didn't think that was a wise position to
take for the projections for the medium
term Financial strategy
um in relation to the risk on Devolution
um yes I I guess there is a risk
attached to Devolution the reason why
it's it's not there is because it's not
a large enough
risk that we can quantify at this stage
um the the difficulty with with risks is
there are some risks which have such a
major impact that like the organization
ceases to exist
um
the evolution is almost in that category
It's relatively remote and if you what
you need to do if you if you want to
provide a commentary on risk never mind
think about
um how you're going to mitigate the
impact of that risk is to assess How
likely it is and what type of
financial impact because this is a
obviously a budget report so the risks
are related to finances that Devolution
for example would have and there are
obviously risks around Evolution
regarding political control and
Democratic accountability in terms of
financial risks of what we know as as
Rochford District Council now is quite
difficult to assess what those risks are
and how we would how we would reduce the
likelihood of those risks and reduce the
impact of those things if they became
manifest and that's why that's not on
the list
did you want to come back on the tourism
point
yes I will do and then I'll see
councilor FD may want to make comment
too as portfolio holder
um completely agree with councilor Eaves
we have got a vibrant District we have a
wealth of culture history and Heritage
here and we should be working with that
to bring people into the district and
for our residents as per reports that
have come in front of this Council over
the last couple of months we have the
shared Prosperity fund a large
proportion of which is going towards
tourism over the next three Financial
years including this one and we also
have the community investment plan which
culture Heritage and tourism plays a
part in so there is already a budget in
place for specifically for tourism where
members and stakeholders can have an
input into what those projects look like
over this financial and the next two
Financial years so whilst there may not
be anything specific within the capital
program we have two specific pots of
money with earmarked funds to go towards
culture tourism Heritage
um for our Rochford District
did you wish to add to that
thank you chair
um thank you for the question Council of
eaves again as councilor Belton says
I've been quite actually quite bullish
in trying to push for some extra funding
for tourism we've been very underfunded
over the last few years
and we've got to have a quite a sizable
trunk of the share plus privity fund and
hopefully something becoming very soon
because we've got to spend the first
lump of it before
my March March March so
um I'll be happy to take questions when
we get near the time another council
meeting or if you're interested or set
up a
an online meeting so we can discuss it
then thank you
your next or my list
thank you chairman um
I think this is my 13th budget meeting
at Rochford and I would just like to say
it's a very different budget process
this year to pre-coverage years
um
pre-covered we were able to contribute
ideas openly
through the budget away day process
under Chatham House Rules I'm sure the
chairman remember those days who was
there then and I felt those days at that
point we had a better budget process we
all understood what's happening much
more
um so I find it much more difficult
working under this process
um I'd also like to say there's a lack
of clarity on how amendments should be
put
to this budget meeting because obviously
they were rarely done before because we
agreed it beforehand
um
I would ask officers can they look at
Essex County Council where the budget
process and the amendment process is
very clear and works very very well I'm
sure as the county councilors here will
agree with that
um turning to the budget itself I'm not
going to say too much about it because
I've got something else to do instead
with regard to the savings we've got an
investment income of 250 000 mentioned
and pension revaluation of 395 000 as
contributing to our savings
um I'd just like to point out these
aren't in the council's control these
are outside effect for also for openness
I perhaps should declare that I'm a
member of the Essex County Council
pension board so we'll have some effect
on the pension revaluation there where
we we decide on the Investments
um so perhaps it's a bit of luck as well
but we have that and I'd also like to
say that I don't disagree with
everything in the budget and there is a
there's a possibly what we might call a
scary possibility that some of us on
this side may be more in control of the
budget next year and maybe it's not
something we we are actually looking
forward to that much because they'll
know and it's a difficult process
um
I just want to turn to reserve General
reserves are up by 200 000 pounds and as
I said last year guidance from set for
suggests it should be around five to ten
percent
and I think we should aim for the lower
amount I'm aware that Tim Willis would
probably say he wants to aim for the
higher amount
but it's a matter of opinion and where
your your risk is
um
as has been said as well I think he's
admitted it that the increasing council
tax is just putting money into our
general reserves and I don't think
that's appropriate at this time it's
also something that councilor Wilkinson
also said
um I think the reserves are there not
for potential loss of income because
we're we're not like a business we're a
council we would exist in in some form
hopefully
for the foreseeable future unless we end
up like thorough so it's not a risk of
loss of income it's a risk of a project
failure I think we want those reserves
high for and I think that's what what is
being done and I don't agree we should
be in that position so I think the the
reserves are too high and they should be
closer to five percent than 10
and I just remember about I mean I've
got to mention I'm sorry Council Wilson
but I just mentioned again about just
one of our earmarked reserves is down to
622 000 pounds due to a payment we had
to make to GP Partnerships so perhaps
we're not that financially or fiscally
responsible as we might like to think
however
I'm now going to turn to some amendments
which I've put through
Tim Willis and I know Andrew Hunkin has
given his view but I'm going to still
put them and perhaps in a slightly
different way which he might find
acceptable
um
so as the independent and green group
we're putting forward three amendments
to the budget or three items for the
budget one
to assist those in need mostly in the
cost of living crisis to provide them
with a subsidy of 80 pounds for ease of
identification everyone on the lcts
which is the local council tax support
scheme
would receive this amount this is not to
be seen as part of the lcts scheme this
is method for identifying people and
making payments to them the cost is 291
200 pounds and we paid for out of
General Reserves
as I said this could be done because
reserves are too high
two
this is um one which possibly isn't too
easy to explain to people who are not
aware about Park Homes but in hold which
we have most of the park home sites in
in the district Park home site fees
are to go up by 14.1 percent rather than
11.1 percent proposed
the site fees
form part of the pitch fees
and the site owners have already put the
pitch fees up by 14.1 percent so I think
we should match their fees otherwise
they're making more money out of the
residents
and I think it's appropriate to do that
three
um
counselors can claim the proposal is
that councilors can claim only one
special responsibility allowance at the
moment they can claim multiple ones this
will obviously have a budgetary effect
with a reduction in the amount paid
overall to councilors however I am happy
given what Andrew Hunkin said to me
earlier that this proposal could be
referred to the Constitutional working
group if that's acceptable
um
finally
and issues for officers as well we were
going to propose a freeze to Mill Hall
prices
however there is some confusion among
users of the whole
who say prices have gone up whilst
officers say they are lower can it just
be please explain I'm getting reports
that people say that they used to pay
350 pounds and now they're paying 417
pounds and the officer said it used to
be 500 pounds so I'd just like some
clarity on that thank you counselor
Hawaii can you just confirm for me your
amendments are in addition to the
recommendations as shown on page 3.24 or
are they amending existing they're in
addition they're addition because
they're they're changing the budgetary
amounts okay and do you have a second
for that
so I could see somebody's hand I can't
see who it is thank you Council Wilson
yeah
um officers
um with regards to those amendments
we're going to have to refer to those in
a second or two is it any possibility we
can get them out of the board
that's a challenge for you
yeah okay
um you had a third you had a third
question there with regards to the fees
who's who can answer that question
he's got us the whole face
regards to the whole phase
[Music]
yes I I can
um answer that thank you chair
um in the same way that I answered it by
email today to council Hawaii
um the specific child that he was
referring to the information I have is
that Fusion were levying charges in
relation to Mill Hall and they were
running it on our behalf
and as an organ as such an organization
they added vat to their charges
um when we were presenting this report
with the proposals in relation to fees
and charges for Mill Hall
um
what we've done is remove the vat
because we consider them those charges
to be exempt which means we don't charge
vat as a public body and that means that
like for like their
they have the 20 excluded from the fee
so from the customer's point of view
they're they're paying less
in reality to the recipient there's no
change in the in the absolute amount of
income in relation to that specific item
the weekends four to eight hours fee for
um for for Mill Hall main hall was
um 500 pounds by fusion and it's 417
pounds by the council from 23-4 that's
the proposal and that is excluding the
um that would that was previously added
on
um I understand councilor Hoy is saying
that that was 350 pound not 500 pounds
um but the information I have is that
that was 500 pounds uh that was one of
about 20 different elements of charge
and I'm not clear whether or not council
is challenging all of those previous
charges or just that specific one but
I've responded to him individually on
that specific one which I've repeated
tonight
um while I have the mic shall I
as we can bear with me just a second
we got all the Amendments on
okay members we need to take the
Amendments first I do have to a couple
other people who wish to speak to the
main
point but
I think they're up on screen I can't
really see it
okay right so
but
so we're just putting a list together so
please there's a couple over there okay
still web
yeah councilor Mrs Dylan
okay Council hoy
can I just ask you to confirm what is on
the screen
you may need to come down and have a
closer look is what your amendments are
essentially yes that's the same I would
point out on put it point one it's lcts
not clts
that's all
okay
okay right
okay now speaking to the amendment and
the amendment only
uh councilor Wilkinson
sorry let's stick your 5p in the meter
can you hear me yeah that's better it's
more of a question chairman actually and
it's so by yourself if I mates for
councilor Hoy um just to confirm those
three amendments uh you say they're in
addition to the amendment to the
proposals in item f
um I assume then that you that includes
the inclusion item F item three so that
includes the proposal number F which is
the increase 2.97 because you've not
amended that at all so
okay so I understand that thank you
okay
Castle web
thank you chairman
um I'd just like to say I support
Council high with Amendment one
recognizing that there is still need in
our district
um I believe there's other groups in
this District that would benefit from a
discretionary payment of some sort
my only concern is in terms of do we
need to actually do some more work to
look at this figure is this the correct
figure should we be looking at a
different figure and is this the right
group to actually give that funding to
as they're already receiving some
additional funding
so I would like to ask that we actually
look at setting up a short task and
finish group cross party to look at
which groups do we need to support
within the district and then I would ask
that we actually find some money from
reserves to make that happen I don't
know that the figure can be agreed
tonight maybe it can be but I'm
certainly supportive of amendment one in
some way shape or form thank you
okay
thank you chairman
um so on Amendment one much like
councilor Webb has just set out
absolutely agree with the principle of a
support Grant I don't necessarily agree
with giving this a grant to those
receiving the council tax support scheme
that we voted on last week those people
are getting that Grant an additional 25
pound from central government and can
benefit from the extraordinary hardship
fund that we set up and much like
Michael councilor microwave has just set
out there are other groups in this
District that may benefit and when I
spoke with councilor Hoya on this item
the the 80 pound is just a figure
there's no meat to those bones per se
and i would support further work being
done to identify who in the district
needs extra support and what that
support looks like as opposed to just
choosing a figure and a group of people
to give additional support to so that's
my views on that one on the Second
Amendment I fully agree with Council
Hoya's suggestion and I thank him for
bringing it to our attention as a
counselor that deals with Park Homes
more than most of us he has the
knowledge and I welcome that advice and
I would support him on that one
in regards to the third I don't think
that's something that we should be
voting on here we all have a pecuniary
interest in it I fully support a review
of allowances and I'm told that we
actually have a review due this year
because it's done every four years the
last time there was a review in 2019 we
we took on every recommendation of that
independent body good and bad the
recommendations were taken on so I would
ask that that recommendation I couldn't
support that recommendation this evening
because it's for an independent body to
review this year anyway and make the
determined suggestions thank you
thank you chairman
um councilor Hoy I completely agree with
all three of your proposed amendments I
think going back to your earlier
statement about previous budget away
days
although they were never attended by all
of the opposition I know you did and if
you had been able to come and bring this
to the table earlier
we will probably have this included
because it obviously gains support
um I agree with councilor Webb that the
finer detail of the amounts might need
to be looked at
um your recommendation three I
wholeheartedly agree with that
although we do have an independent
review we don't have to go with what
they suggest they might like to give us
more money but we don't have to take it
thank you thank you chairman
I can't
I haven't broken it
okay counselor ease
thank you chairman just a very quick
point on uh item one it has been
suggested that there'd be more work done
on this on this as
um has been mentioned many times on
these kind of things could we put a time
scale on it please I would venture to
suggest that before perder would be a
good one to aim for thank you
yeah
councilor Mrs Wilson
thank you chair I'd just like to make a
comment regarding point one
um regarding the um
lcts
um yeah I've just got a query regarding
uh the ad the 80 pound payment and for
what use that will go to
um I think people have had
maybe not enough but certain people have
had certain
um have had quite a large amount of
support from the government already I
fully
um agree with what councilor Webb said
and if he would like to formalize his
proposal I would be really happy to
second because I think that would
be really good to actually look what we
can do for our local residents I totally
agree with the task and finish group
thank you
okay
council Mrs Wilson we can't take another
proposal at this stage
so bear with us a second or two right is
anybody else wish to speak to these
amendments
customers Wilson
sorry I will get the hang of this
eventually can we can we take an
amendment instead is that allowed no we
need to deal with this particular
Amendment first okay thank you okay
um
I just want to refer to the 80 pounds
okay this work I did in July last year
with
Naomi Lucas when she was here
and um arrived at the figure then so I
might agree that the the figure might be
out of date by now I'll just use the
same figure as we worked then but I
didn't go ahead with this then because
we weren't providing support ourselves
with the government grant that was all
if there was any advice from officers
whether or not we can amend our own
amendment I don't know thank you Council
hoy
with regards to your amendments there
that you've heard a number of issue
items that have been raised do you wish
to update your Amendment because I can
take amendments to your Amendment
unadvised so you may wish to update your
remembrance taken in on board
what has been suggested and said
um I mean I'm willing to amend the first
one
I'm I would need officer advice because
I obviously it was mentioned a task and
Finnish group quite quickly but I think
if we said three months it's right in
the middle of the election I would guess
so yeah that might not be appropriate so
I'll take can I have some help from
offices and we might be appropriate or
from councilor belt and when she might
think appropriate as well okay let me
take some advice on that Council
yeah
Mr Wilson
thank you chair
um if I may I I just wanted to offer the
council some advice in relation to the
um Amendment as originally described by
councilor Hawaii as well
um
the um
I'm a little concerned
um in that I'm the statutory finance
officer for this Council and the council
when agreeing the budget
needs to be very mindful of what the
statutory finance officer says in his or
her Assurance statement that gives you
the assurance that it's okay it's legal
and the the estimates have been put
together accurately and there's
sufficient Reserves
and
it's my judgment my professional
judgment that you rely upon that's why
I'm here
um I'll draw your attention to page 322
there's a table of reserves there
and discussion about we have plenty of
reserves we're putting money into
Reserves
you can you can see envelope
Castle I can't hear you yeah we have to
wait for it to be turned on
um
we have had this before I'm not here to
debate officers I think it's quite clear
we're proposing this to go to a task of
Finnish Group which is when office
officers can then input into it we're
not the the amendment now is to move
this hopefully to a task of Finnish
Group which will finish quickly which
officers can then input to to say
whether it's legal or not within our
policy or not but we're not here to
debate officers officers should not be
debating with us we should be debating
amongst ourselves
to get to at the end of what he wanted
to say
thank you chair
um I would absolutely never want to
debate with members a council meeting
never mind the budget meeting I was
hopefully just pointing out
my statutory obligations and powers in
relation to this Council and the budget
um and it's me not any other counselor
that the council itself as a whole
should be listening to when it comes to
the robustness of the estimates and the
Assurance statement
um in relation to the following on the
actual point
um I've spoken briefly to my head of
Revenue benefits in relation to the
practicalities of uh such a payment
being made and how we would
deal with that and it is complex even if
we can in some way separate it from the
actual scheme the local council tax
support scheme there are a number of
um related questions that we would need
to bottom out before we could Implement
such a such an idea what if people have
council tax of years do we still pay it
is there an effective date
what if people fall into the support
scheme during the year or is it is it
paid pro-rata there are a number of
other issues that we would need to
address so I'd be reluctant to give a
time frame within which we'll be able to
deliver this
girls Mrs Wilson
yesterday the the a member that has been
put forward by councilor Hoy is that
what you wish to have added or is there
something additional to that
no that is actually what I was asking
for and if if appropriate I'm very happy
to second
okay
is that appropriate the amendment has
been uh seconded by councilor Mr Wilson
oh sorry it has sorry so I won't jump in
the middle of that I'll leave you to
sort that out when you get home
um uh wrong Mr Wilson just saying just
saying I apologize
the real one is also in the room don't
cause a domestic okay
by confusion
okay thank you
okay thank you I'm quite confused what
are we point one because Council I asked
the question of the time frames if we
went into a
quick working party we voting on that or
we're sticking to the original
amendment that Council I put in
I'm a little bit confused on this now
okay thank you
I think I need a little bit of
clarification here because
if we go with uh the amendment of
council Hawaii's one with a time frame
can you give me a time frame on that
so
hang on just a second okay
we're trying to get get some answer to
that in a second
chairman I just want to check with
councilor Hoy uh whether or not we are
now moving down the route of looking at
a task and finish group and if we are
then I believe I have some wording which
I've scribbled here but I should be able
to decipher if that would be helpful
uh yes we are
okay if you'd like to read that out for
me please yes uh chairman listening to
what members have said then I would be
suggesting something like that the
overview and scrutiny committee and I'll
just say because you already have that
here sets up a time limited working
group to set up to determine whether a
payment should be made to Residents
affected by the cost of living crisis
within the districts including to whom
how how it should be resourced and
financial amounts
Council Ahoy
are you happy with that wording
oh yes thank you chairman that's what I
wanted okay thank you
councilor FD does that satisfy your
point of order yes thank you chairman
does this need a second or is it covered
by the first second it's covered by the
first second thank you thank you
councilor
Mrs Mason oh disappeared
okay council Mrs Mason you indicated to
speak
[Music]
I seem to have a slight problem
which is more painful than I'd like to
describe yes um
yes
I'm not quite sure because the original
um motion Amendment seems to have got
lost one thing I would like to ask and
be concerned about is the effect on the
budget because the budget at the moment
is balanced
um I'm hoping that the officers comments
will have um be able to clarify that
thank you
yes thank you chair
um and thank you for that question
councilor this is Mason it's helpful for
me to be able to make that point if the
council had been minded to approve the
amendment then I before you did so then
I would have been advising you that
we don't have 291 000 spare in next
year's budget to fund it and so I would
be advising you as the statutory officer
not to approve it because to do so you
would not be approving a balanced budget
but that's not the case and we are going
to be
looking into this and the practicalities
of its implementation after this budget
is set
that's
that's something that we should be
comfortable with because from tomorrow
if this budget is approved by council
tonight things will change it will be
immediately out of date
all sorts of things will change that we
have no control over whatsoever it's
just our best guess
with lots of professional judgment but
it's just our best guess so this along
with a hundred other things will happen
in the coming days weeks and months as
we go through 23 24 that will change the
budget we will be having the
budget monitoring report coming to
Executive
um soon for quarter three
and if that is going to I don't know
what what it is yet but if that is
suggesting that we're going to have an
under spend this year that's something
new that we don't know when we set next
year's budget now and that could provide
some resource it's just one example of
things that could change if it's an
overspend we'll have a another problem
so what I'm trying to describe is there
is lots of uncertainty and having such a
review as this is one of it's just
another one of those uncertain things
that will occur during the course of
2034 that we'll do our best to try and
address and fund if possible if Council
want it
right next on my list is counselor Mrs
Belton
thank you my Point's slightly out of
time now because it was in response to
council Ahoy originally asking a
question and one thing I would say
though we have a cost of living
um working group we have a cost of
living team that are nationally
recognized doing fantastic work and when
this if this is passed that I would
support this amendment now
um I would just ask the ons look at the
work being done by the cost of living
group there's a dashboard there showing
us who is the most in need and it's not
the people that we automatically look at
every time so I think I would really
welcome this work being done and I would
say do it in conjunction with the cost
of living team who have got an awful lot
of valuable data and headed up by Tracy
Lilly who who's been doing some good
work there
okay members we need to move this to the
vote
councilor hoy what I would ask you to do
is if you'd like to read out your
amendments one by one
and I will take the vote on them
individually so if you'd like to read
out your first amendment
thank you chairman
that the ons committee set up a time
limited working group to determine
whether payments should be made to
Residents within the district affected
by the cost of living crisis including
to whom how sources of funding and
financial amounts
do you want me to read them out no we'll
do one at a time thank you Council hi
members those in favor please indicate
okay members that is unanimous thank you
and that will be added to the list at
item
is it oh I think it's going to be forgot
me off of it right Council Hawaii would
you like to read out your second
amendment thank you chairman
Park home site fees increased by 14.1
percent rather than 11.1 percent
okay members those in favor
can you keep your hands up please
thank you members that's unanimous and
that will become Item B
okay Council Hawaii or third amendment
thank you
that members can only claim one special
responsibility allowance and to refer
the matter to IRP
which I think is very independent review
panel remuneration panel
okay members those in favor
those against
any ascensions
okay that's the numbers please
okay members 34 4 and three abstentions
that is carried and will become item Q
that's correct you okay now
okay
okay going back to our original list
because of the world
thank you very much chairman can I ask
for a quick Comfort Blake please
yeah I think that's going to be
acceptable uh I'll suspend the process
of the proceedings for 10 minutes
so thanks okay so so on that basis then
I'll I'm quite happy with the rest of
them because obviously they're figures
that we need to approve but I can't
support that for the same reasons I
couldn't support it in the previous vote
thank you Jim
Castle Hawaii
I got a wife and I might come up
try that
you know
hopefully that works now yes
um could I just have confirmation from
Tim Willis that all these points are
really just adding up aren't they so
we're not agreeing the figures we're
just saying these figures add up to this
and if you take this figure it agrees to
that figure that's my understanding of
it
yes thank you that is that is correct
councilor it is a technical paper in
that you've you've agreed the council
tax increase for next year in the budget
report what this does is reflect all the
background calculations that go to make
up the total counter tax of which the
district council share is just one
component it includes all the other
preceptors in the in this what is a
standard report that almost the same
Report with different numbers appears in
front of all councils across the country
at this time of year thank you
nobody else is indicating
members we have a number of items here
are you happy that I take these on block
okay
it was worth a shot
sorry at the risk of going through the
same as we went through for the last one
I only object to one of them I'm quite
happy to support the others and I don't
know if anybody else in this side of the
chamber feels the same way that might
save a bit of time
okay which ones do you not so which one
do you buy some f chairman is the only
one I I will vote differently on
yeah
sorry if I may uh members this is there
is only one recommendation here and uh
you know our server section 151 officer
is set out these are all related to it
to each other
can you clarify does that mean I take
them or block or not
yeah
members are being advised that I need to
take them on block
on a point of order I'm sorry I I with
the greatest respect I don't see how
that can be the case the last item we
spoke on had several recommendations all
of which were numbered or lettered on
the side this is exactly the same there
are certain aspects of this which I
agree with there were certain aspects of
this which I do not agree with and I
will not accept having to vote with them
on blog I don't see what the difference
is perhaps see monetary officer could
explain
uh
foreign
I can only just reiterate what my advice
is you do have one recommendation uh
here and there is a correlation between
all of these uh recommendations sorry
all of these proposals within the
recommendation
Bell
I'm just going to say it again no one's
actually agreeing with the amounts the
figures in terms of what we're charging
what we're doing this is purely a
technical sum of what's just been agreed
it's been noted those that didn't agree
with the increase so that's already
public record this is purely adding the
numbers up now it doesn't mean you're
now in support of the increase that you
weren't in support of before it's a
technical paper only and not actually in
terms of opinions so to speak it's it's
maths
yeah
Castle lumen
thank you chairman simple as my life is
um
if it's just a matter of a run-on from
the previous vote while we voting for
this at all
if this is purely an 89 process totaling
process of what we've already voted why
on Earth have I got an item to vote on
that's already been approved
Mr Williams can you please explain oh oh
try a chair
um my colleague admonish Pastor might be
able to help me here because it's it's
legal
um but um it's in relation to sections
31 to 36 of the act so the 5.1 is saying
the council resolves that the following
amounts
now calculated by the council for the
year in accordance with sections 31 or
30 to 36 of the act so what it's asking
for approval on is that the the
calculations that sit behind the
consequence of approving the council tax
increase
um are as follows and then it lists all
the recommendations A2 to H and as as F
points out it doesn't say for the
council to approve
the council tax for wellsford District
Council 252 pound 45 which is a 2.97
increase next year that's the previous
report what it's saying is that the that
252.45 is the amount
based on the following calculation
so to vote against it in simple terms
will be to argue that the calculation is
wrong not that the principle of a
council tax increase is wrong
casual lawn
hey German if I'll come back or not it's
a fighter completely I mean I mean we
voted something why are we why are we
discussing it's voted for it and we've
just got to accept the officer's remarks
that these figures are as a continuance
of the previous bug surely I don't get
it because it's very confusing to me why
am I having two stabs at the Clinton
thing you know just don't get it
um I'll I understand it it appears a bit
illogical but it's the law and it's the
law because Russia District Council is a
collection Authority so the council
collects council tax on behalf of the
County police fire and the parishes and
it's because of that that we need to the
council needs to approve this report
because what we're saying is we've done
all the calculations based on all of the
precept advice we've had from all of
those other precepting bodies we collect
all that money in and then we pay over
to them during the year and what this is
attempting to do is to say if we add
together all of the income that we'll
generate from all of those precepts
because we're going to collect it all
and it's broken down in this way that's
the calculation so the other preceptors
will look at this report and say what's
the district council have done the
calculation they've got our share of
what they're collecting and they're
going to pay it over to us that's the
principle behind the ACT which underpins
this report which is a statutory council
tax resolution report and as I say in
this format almost identical format with
obviously different numbers the same
report is agreed by every Council must
be agreed by every council at this time
of year across the country
and again calcium Wilkinson can you
please keep it brief yeah I will do
chairman yeah thank you so I do I accept
exactly what Mr Willis is saying um I
just got a question though really is um
for memory this is only my fourth year
in this Council but I don't remember
ever having to recommend having to vote
on block like this before so well we've
got a different set of people up at the
front that we've had previously so did
we do it wrong in the past or why are we
doing it differently this year I just
need some to understand this really
because we've always been able to vote
separately on this if we've disagreed
that
my memory tells me different Council of
Wilkinson I'm afraid
okay
uh councilor Mrs Mason
I
think the officers explained it
exceptionally well we have done the same
academic exercise every year in my
memory
I I can understand that certain members
might feel uncomfortable with it but
they have the option of voting against
it
um if they so wish but it is very much a
technical document very much a procedure
if you like and it's just for public
record it's we're not agreeing or
disagreeing we're just explaining so
perhaps can I suggest that the folk be
put thank you
no okay right I'm going I've listened to
your points of order thank you members
uh I'm going to go for a block vote
for the for all of the items uh from a
to
J that's all pages 4.4 and 4.5
all those in favor
okay thank you members those against
any abstentions
31 4
zero against
and six abstentions thank you members
okay members
the gender item five
is allocation of seats on committees
members the interim director for people
and governance Andrew Hunkin will now
introduce the reports
thank you chairman uh the council agreed
the uh the constitution of the council's
Committees on the 13th of December 2022
but not the nominations to those
committees an addendum to item five has
been tabled based on the nominations as
at the 13th of December but amended to
reference any political composition
changes up to the 20th of February and
the independent group's resolution to
nominate to the chief officers
appointments committee thank you chair
okay any members wish to speak to this
item
okay thank you
okay I'll move that from the from the
chair
except thank you for Mr fashion
okay members there's one recommendation
on page 5.4 of the documentation
um
it is proposed that the council resolves
one that the members be appointed to
serve on the Committees for the
remainder of the
2022-23 municipal year
those in favor
okay thank you members
those against
any abstentions
okay
well that's 36 in favor
zero against zero abstentions that are
one non-voting I make that thank you
members that that item is now carried
members just before I I closed the
meeting I'd like to thank you for your
time this evening and I'd just like to
extend my apologies to both Mr
councilman Mr Wilson and councilor Mrs
Wilson for the confusion earlier on I do
apologize for that
I assume that Mr Wilson accepts your
apology too
thank you members I make that 1006
I'm going to close the meeting thank you
members